you had to tremendous reaction to the
mini episode we perform again yes yes it
was good well III would be very worried
about having two doctors sharing the
lunchbox how does that work which of
them is more important than the other
which is the junior doctor which is the
senior doctor I'm not sure that works I
think there has to be one dr. Pereira i
think paul mcgann was superlative in
that I think do you know what I honestly
think he's gonna end up playing some big
old lady because I know he already has
that kind of thing but I think he showed
a flash of his leading man abilities we
see them quite in that dashing form for
a while he's gonna end up doing
something interesting off the back of
the hat no question you know what's
really important with a night of the
doctor it's not that it was Paul McGann
brilliant as it was it's not that he had
a bloody surprise you know back in the
day we used to do those so don't spoil
anything but you know I mean that's what
it was and I'd like to do that again I
liked I I think that will usher in not
not so much a Paul McGann miniseries it
will usher in the idea that when we when
our little menace orders would call them
hideous name but we call them that I
think we should take them more seriously
than we used to and that's the first one
we've got is that I said let's make
let's make a belter let's make a high
production value belt on let's give them
a surprise you could count on us doing
something but like that like that again
but we won't tell you when I'm not I've
actually said that I back told the BBC
if we do it again we're doing in card
I'm not telling what we're doing and
what I will give you on the day right I
won't tell you anything well I don't
know yeah cuz he's all he's barely
started but he's a genius he's a genius
actor no one knows not even
controversial to say he's a great love
of the part he's got the moment you
think is Peter Capaldi is the doulton
you get it you see that face in the
TARDIS that works everybody gets that
he's going to he's just gonna give us a
whole new kind of doctor we've got used
to I suppose - brilliant iterations
really brilliant iterations of the
younger
a more popular doctor and that's a real
part and there and they have both been
superlative now it's time to remain that
now it's time for the old beast to snarl
at you were better I'd say I mean I mean
sometimes you see that in Matt's method
times as well sometimes he does show you
he will remind the people around it I'm
not really like this
well I think I think Peters doctor will
make that even clearer I didn't mind it
going earlier I didn't I just went on
one of the Doctor Who blog sites and
sighs photograph then I thought you
bastards
because there were people in years
enough people in you most of them had
the common human decency to to take
their mouth shut but one or two people
have to be show offs and that was
disappointing but but then then but then
it's sort of um it sort of rather work
for us because I said let's let's just
let's just be mean let's give them an
hour let's just say in an hour's time
get your iPlayer talk to nobody and that
was a good way of doing it that's a bit
more showbiz at all just that for you
know because the one point it was in we
should call it - Paul McGann in the last
regeneration that would've had no impact
at all you didn't know what you were
going to see but a whole bunch of Doctor
Who fans sitting down click on their
computers there he is
possibly not the one you were expecting
and that that was great I love that
enough
you